let's talk about
this main story right here facebook
meets apple in the clash of the tech
titans i mean are there two bigger
companies in the world right now
like straight up apple and facebook
what's that what's
amazon maybe right yeah obviously not
for sure okay but
two of the biggest companies in the
world and zuck
quote unquote says we need to inflict
pain here's the story when facebook was
embroiled in controversy over its
data collection practices tim cook in a
national television interview said
that his own company would never have
found itself
in such a jam zuck shot back
to cook's comments saying saying they
were extremely glib
and not aligned with the truth and in
private zuck was even harsher he says
we need to inflict pain can i get the
italian accent of that
i don't do italians okay i got you we
need to inflict pain on this guy
that's where you're going with that we
need to inflict pain he told his team
in private how'd that get out in the
public we can address that
facebook and apple's visions are
diverging and increasingly
incompatible facebook wants to capture
and monetize eyeballs listen up now
facebook wants to capture and monetize
eyeballs
on every possible device and platform
apple on the other hand
wants to draw users to its own hardware
centric universe partly by marketing
itself as a private
focused company underline that i'm sorry
a privacy
focused company last summer apple
announced the app tracking transparency
tool
which once rolled out will
allow ad tracking only if consumers
opt in when they receive a prompt on an
iphone or ipad
the change means that facebook and other
companies would no longer be able to id
to collect a person's advertising
identifier
without permission and in the face of
pushback from facebook and others apple
delayed the rollout
of this new tool for a few months but
said late last month it will arrive
early
this spring kai i know that you got some
strong feelings on this
you were excited to address this topic
what are your thoughts uh i'm definitely
team apple on this one
i think uh privacy is something
important that a lot of us don't even
understand of how
they're able to track and how they can
be in the background and stuff like that
so i think
definitely privacy is something that we
should be more aware of
now from what i've understood on this
app you can either say
allow or don't allow so it's not like
they're completely cutting off like if
you really want facebook in the
background lurching
to see who's clicking allow so they can
i don't know we'll see
what did you do to my phone yesterday we
clicked allow no no we clicked not
allowed
no no we you you got it mixed you
clicked you allowed me
it was it was not allowed and then we
allowed it why would you allow that
because then you can get better ads
they can monetize you i'm coming after
you but uh but yeah you can finish
yourself so yes
i'm definitely more on apple's side here
i think um the only argument that
i know facebook is making is that small
businesses will have a
harder time targeting people because you
don't have the same
uh actions you're thinking of small
businesses right now that's what they're
that's the card they're playing
that who facebook yes they're saying
what other card do they have no that
they're creepy and just
watching you in the background what'd
you call it would you call it what was
the analogy it's like
it's like a creepy old uncle at a at a
at a children's uh birthday party or
something like that where you have you
used quinceanera yesterday yeah
the point is it's creepy exactly because
that's what you're in that's the analogy
for facebook
yeah cause they're creeping they're
they're creeping in the background
seeing
looking at where you are all this stuff
like that and i think for most people
we're not even aware of it
and something like that is they're
selling the data just like crazy trying
to make so kai is coming out he's saying
he is on team apple i'm on team privacy
team privacy yes are you on kai's team
or are you
you're going somewhere else with this
time yeah i'm not going to start
agreeing with kai i'm not
my first time on a podcast i'm not going
to make him feel like yeah then he
already he's already feeling too good
you know what
no as a matter of fact steal his swag
you know how dare you number one how
dare you you come on this show
thompson you have a comment like that no
i like bickering ceos number one i think
that's great for america
i think that's great for news i'd like
to see more ceos
personally whenever i see zuck v cook i
always go cook
i mean come on zach how do you root for
him right you're not i just
i think zuck after 10 years of being you
know full frontal on american
pop culture and tech and everything i
think you're going to be inclined to
not believe anything he says right away
that's my first are you saying that cook
is more believable 100 percent
you know 100 like like do you trust
apple more or facebook guys
apple here's here's the deal here does
anybody here not have an apple iphone
7 i know you know you were an android
and we had to like
convince you not so subtly to switch it
up just because
you know you you trust them more on the
surface they might be actually more
devious
yeah i mean who knows he might just be
playing us all but
but cook comes across as the non-creepy
uncle i mean he kind of comes across as
that uncle
but maybe not as creepy one more point
here you know you look at facebook
you look at apple you get some of these
other tech companies their market cap
is about equivalent to the gnp of some
countries
so you know what i think that means they
should have armies they should have
their own military
if facebook has a problem with google
they can send tanks over there
if you're looking for a hot war i mean
look this would escalate a little bit
more
um it would be interesting you got beef
with kai this morning you know
you want to you know get these ceos
shooting and my last point is
and i made this the other day a little
bit i think there's more room just in
general for stories like this
i think something like this or other
stories would fall by the wayside
because eighty percent of the stories in
the past were all politics we're all
trump
we're all elected he's just taking the
oxygen out he's sucking it all out of
the room so now you have the opportunity
to have these discussions where maybe
you wouldn't have heard about them
before
or maybe in actuality they're no big
deal but we get to discuss it is this a
big deal
i think facebook versus apple is a
pretty damn big dude i mean it's a big
deal but when you use the quote
we need to inflict pain yeah that's a
pretty big deal but you know what
something like that is all context too i
mean
we need to inflict pain right you don't
think you did it like hey you know like
a stalin type
what was cook thinking there man maybe
we got inflicted a little pain back i
mean it's just how you say it and but he
said it in private so like how does that
get leaked
somebody on the team is saying sounds
like facebook is doing some privacy
stuff
yeah maybe in
maybe the guy a boomer like me didn't
know how to use the thing and he did
the young buck like you no but i mean
and i disagree with tom at one point of
of
he says he'd trust facebook or apple
more because
or you don't know if we can trust apple
more one thing that comforts me is
apple makes a lot of money selling this
phone they don't need to only monetize
the data on the phone or the private so
that aspect of it
i trust that they're making i mean
thousands of dollars on the equipment
and the hardware and then you're
plugged into the ecosystems they're not
relying on the monetization of only
the data that they're selling to
monetizers however with facebook it's
free
i don't see a lot of people spending
money on like the facebook i mean they
have like the portal
and a bunch of other hardware that
they're selling but i don't see a lot of
people spending money on that
kai do me a favor break that down in
plain english what are you saying right
there
you're giving me hardware data mining
facebook probably only makes money or
mostly like 99
of their money by selling ads say that
again slowly facebook makes
money 99 of your money you said
hypothetically
okay the majority of their money by
selling ads
people pay money for ads ads the more
all businesses you were talking about
small businesses
probably mostly big businesses yes the
more ads they sell
or the more data the ads have the more
they can target
the better the geo targeting and stuff
geo phishing
yes they're targeting that term
correctly no not at all they'll tar
though
okay however they target they can they
can choose so the more data they have
available
yeah the better they can target that's
how they make their money
which means they need more creepy phones
than anything in the background so they
can
so what you're saying is facebook makes
their money by creeping
pretty much so listen to the stat i got
a stat i just pulled up here mario
as for the fourth quarter earnings
facebook reported 28.1 billion in
revenue of which 27.2 billion came from
ads
yes given the numbers 8.1 let me bring
this up so you guys can see it too
but and inside by mario over there
he's coming saying 90 something percent
of their money was ads i don't think
that's breaking news though right no
and with apple they're making money on
subscriptions
they're making money well they're
obviously selling phones they're selling
products
exactly hardware number four what do you
got there mario
yeah so 2020 point 97.9 percent
ninety eight percent yeah so you said
ninety nine percent you were
you were right you were right yeah i was
throwing it out there what's the percent
or two
what price is right rules you went over
oh
you're out bob barker all right what was
the quote by uh
happy girl what was the quote happy
gilmore by the way
just turned 25 years old the price is
wrong the price is wrong
[ __ ] i didn't know if we're gonna say
that oh i said it i went there
okay shout out to my good friend adam
sandler long distance cousin of mine
um happy gilmore is no that was a
classic
and then bob parker right down the hill
years old and then bob barker rest in
peace
beat the living crap out of happy
gilmore he just did the he just did his
swing again
he did his infamous swing we saw that
and then shooter mcgavin
shooter uh came in and gave a little uh
uh throwback to the scene but um where
were we going with that sorry
bob barker price is wrong uh paul
weighed in no so yeah
so long story short i trust apple more
simply because they're not relying on
the data to make money
i see what you're saying we are exposing
the truth here guys mario's crunching
numbers what are your thoughts here you
up with facebook i i learned yesterday
that i got a lot of app uh things going
on in the background yeah
what was the one thing that now we're
going to talk about the fjords thing we
talked about fjords
yesterday my buddy sbj um
we talked about oh you're from norway i
want to go to norway and see the fjords
and two minutes later we get off the
phone he's getting uh ads
on facebook for fjords fjords are like
norwegian rivers yes
they're about their valleys and fjords
peaks and valleys exactly
which is very light and so facebook was
creeping on the come up in the
background
yep that's what yeah i i'm on team apple
here bro all right i've been on t about
team apple since i switched from my
blackberry in like 2010. there you go
when did you get uh
your first item about that time yeah i
do kind of miss the blackberry though
you could do some things like that what
could you do i don't remember what you
could do
you had a bigger keyboard i mean if
you're like writing and things like that
um it had a thing for each letter a key
for each letter but i
i think they should bring back the flip
phone i mean i think i would buy a flip
phone if they brought it back i would
have that as an alternate
i just unlocked for a nostalgia purpose
i think it's more dramatic when you're
done you just like make that noise i'm
done with you click
now you're just like a razor motorola
released a razor
well eric obviously still has a as a
flip phone
well he just had that before he went
over to iphone congratulations
on living in the uh modern era 2020.
yeah paul who's your mic buddy yeah
there's one other story uh that i want
to bring up
but remember in i think it was like san
bernardino in california
there was a a a terrorist yes a domestic
terrorist guy
a handful of years ago yeah 2015. and um
they wanted to go after
uh the the police department wanted to
go after fbi want to go under his uh
phone data and apple said no that's part
of our
user agreement we don't we're not
allowed to give out private information
wow so
that's a huge to me a huge example of
them being pro
uh consumer pro private i think they're
even on a terrorist attack that's no
there's
more to the story well i think you have
to get an affidavit you have to go
through the court system essentially
fbi wanted to to create for them to hack
and essentially create a back door to
access the phone without having to wait
for the court data and stuff like that
because they were saying there would be
a second there was possibilities of
being a second attack
apple then said that uh if they created
an opening or a back door
into it that could be then transferred
on other phones which would
decrease the privacy and security of the
access to
privacy is a real thing that's what
we're saying guys privacy is a real
thing
and you can choose to yeah allow it or
not allow it on your
phone yes and just you gotta give cook a
lot of credit because
that's leadership when you think about
it because it would be you know it's
almost like
you'd want to give that to the
authorities especially i mean that was
brutal that happened in december of 2015
and they go into these office buildings
and they shot all these employees it was
horrible um and you would think yes if
this could stop a future one it takes a
lot of guts to say no
you know the bigger picture here is more
important
respect i mean it says right here
facebook and apple's visions are
diverging and increasingly incompatible
incompatible what does that mean what
does that mean exactly is facebook not
going to be on the iphone
no it's just i mean they'll be there
they're going opposite directions yeah
they are
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye